the customized minis celebrated their
first success in the run-up to the
famous rally
the cars developed and built by sven
funds company x-rayed have now received
bmw's official support
being recognized is of course a triumph
we fought for it long enough i live by
the motto never give up there's always a
way to achieve something if you have the
stamina
the car's journey to the desert began in
the 1990s when sven's father herbert
fund co-owned bmw at the time sven was
on the board of battery producer vata
and was also a regular driver in the
dakar rally
exactly
it was like 14 days of therapy when you
came back you were different from how
you were when you went often with new
ideas about how to tackle things in life
or in business
set about modifying bmw models to fit
them for the purpose
after 10 years development stefan
petronzelle won the rally twice in the
mini
this year the car's biggest threat is
the buggy which has 100 times more
horsepower than the mini
they both have advantages to have a good
chance of winning now the question is
whether the stretch is better suited to
buggies or all-terrain vehicles
now a 9 000 kilometer long jewel over
completely new terrain will determine
whether sven kron's success story
continues